[музика]
ми сьогодні до мене сьогодні розбавляємо вже
марій ел am саакашвілі пари буємо а у
ківі екс-губернатор одещини елітарного
створивши ногу руку нових сиру Михайло odea
go чіпа видалася дата інтерв'ю я хочу
приїхав і нібито собі спочиваєте після
адже ставкою тому що навіть добрі там
ще повстання місяці можу перебування в
одесі
я хоч і вич його в Петрі мк у людей
судно було і кайся на пружині
існуванню з людьми напруженість
якогось спілкування з людьми, а зараз люди
набагато привіт нічого не петри миють
підходить усюди умовності знята можна на
рисі пам'ятати вмовить і в сочі думаю
повністю говорити все що думаю вона
нижчого на всякі думав і казав і але за
радикальності просто і ноги доводилося
вчилася на каже і ось і все а так все
в основному це місце тут щось настрибався
порошенку теж ви мене корупції в
україні
на цьому принципі я майже у самої
замовляється було зароджує тонкою
вуаллю закрито за рости вуаль знято в
в принципі вона їсть облік нічого
поганого валу toomai був дружний з ручним
дар служба всім так скажемо ви ви на
своєї історії intel фейсбуку розмістю і
ти б витягти матеріалі вікі підтвердити
вашу тісну дружбу з але вибраним
президентом США дональдом трампом і
daikin у заднього за цій парі мати
важливим поважного суду змусиш
ментам вам life ти такий хлопець вони
до речі теж борець істеблішментом mauve
мстить таке порівняння по-перше це ну
по porsche і ясна потрібні мис плака
у всьому виразки чайну різанини біографії
абсолютно різьблені мої нові стану часто
суті вони вдосталь і нареченої біля ментів
то прямого застосування німа алекс і
світлові тренд та світлові тренд у там
ще в союз тусувався політичну
коректність і могли бути 100 км анапа
ви на ніби це ми всіх хто з так виріз
а ви поки що фейсбука і ріжте доступні
комунікації знову дружини проц я
політика я заперечив осям вона стала дуже
жорстку вийшла за стіною парламенті
закритих біля льодових засідань
уряду закритих останина стало
соціальним режи осі іскра виразу та
доводить тебе ви зараз борід і себе за
свої міс і доводиться весь час
боротися за своє місце
про swiss творив і нову політичну силу
рук нових сил я до ваших це поки що ваша
мета нашим це очевидно зради ти
український політичний клас вилиці
президент порошенко пропливав ми не
стати прем'єр-міністром я сказав все
розумний вона багата вище амбіцій низ
прем'єр-міністри хто і сказав ти хочеш
стати президентом і сказав не їжте ви
ще я хочу повністю змінить і правила
політичної гри повністю змінити та
політичною класикою ви знімете я хочу
ніби шукає стає до процесу щоб
україна ранку мало новий політичний
клас і цех станьте нашим це
україна політично класики відразу буду
йти 25 року в я пам'ятаю бага темних
середині дев'яностих у ньому давав і
україни дістану найбідніші україни в
європі за ввп на душу населення
потрібно було мати віднімати пілота шкуру
psy
бездарності на ефективність ще психозу
яхти та випалимо мати вищий пілотаж
корупції бездарності
неефективно, щоб ці люди чемпіони злу
дарства чемпіони за віком там навчальні
годинник політичний класний мужик роботи
дали україну even себе вичерпав вирішив
себе
ви виступаєте за дасть рукою вибори на
накопичиться реалістично і на штучках
потреба у нас не буде я ще але сни
будуть дасть рукавах виборі досі два з
чим із рук і буде вся радомир язику та
мотре madhouse отримати проблему в тому
що статус-кво нам вузли виклики значенням
в Україні за раз реально стагнації
економіки нам мвф і будинкового 3 манікюр в
бога траншу через корупцію
рубці на вітер нібито губитися ми будемо
віку ти ж зазвучати бєлянкін
адже їхнє диво порожні
тисячі виймаю терапію кому досягнемо
рівня 2013 року top to as the new уроку
ліну ковача через п'ятнадцять рогів отримай
через 15 років не думаю що українські
істота готові чика ти менше покоління
щебет та ажурі поза януковичем
ти раз це у нас буде стагнація екзо
разів після такого валу чесного падіння
якому 3 мани то в Україні будуть
серйозні проблеми з регіональним
сепаратизмом за ум таку слабкий кістки і
непопулярності влади за розумом або
герметизації ті і влада ви час мистецтва
можна уявити ворогів і чистіше у нас
сотні тисяч вибраних людей бігають на
підлозі потрібен і задавала не вчить його що на
сотні тисяч озброєних людей бігати
потім ще не можеш чекає remato через
інститут та влада висловлювання своїх
політично пошкодивши щось озвученому
різак йому матеус броні house бо а та
інших поганих промов досвіду статус-кво в
загартовані харчування та харчування будуть і
виходять і дулати статус-кво через закис
з броні access обидва через архівний шлях
він і давньої української історії davichi
розпускав і роду розпуску ви кучма
ющенко жадібна чіпай один залишився у
буде муразе вибори циви рішення
політичний щур голові політично щур
на щиті посилала на економічну крайову
проблемами пов'язана ми свиною у
і так далі те, що береш демократії тим
найсильніші буду тримаючи ось їм найсильніші
буду країна зростання з цим сильнішим буде
солі давай поїдемо а вигадує якщо своєї
ми ти хоч студентський кущі людей
кіблі на вашому мітингу бог ще в
suspect і на моє обожнювання змінила ти
владу на high with будуть ці вибори 2017
уроку
наскільки я розумію на найпопулярнішому
політикам зараз їй Юлія тимошенко і як
ви думаєте що буду собою
нового рада з буду знову ти мошонку
можна виривати
опозиційного блоку я спіткнемось партії
регіоні все зміните стоп а мене
я абсолютно цілком ще на людину буде
їх на ступнях виборах у загарі гугняво
там бути заново їх три зрозуміє ще тут
видувається після іншого майдану і люди
тут за нісенітницю було раціональними novice
хто ви маєте на меті придумати які їх у
в тому числі ми знаємо про все-таки люди як
Юлія Марушевська цикл із не заступники
міністрі вікі добрий себе
зарекомендували цикл із неї голови наших
районі vc волонтери а що за пропливала
і пісня друга майдану люди взяли владу
водних у януковича
Іван Ільїн і могли забрати цю хату
правильно і вони не могли просто
брати з собою тому прогони кому сеппо ви
не були парі дати
ви не вивернуло кулак сидів і сказала але
він їм акуму біля мережі самі і зрадив її
цивілізованішим шим позаду старих нібито to
die був та на вигляд він зрадив їх нові мало
запасів дружині na'vi у тому затишку та катання
на світ був ася революції сильний і в лося
революційних змін кесслер валюті та
курячі будьте раваль then is mine
обидва настою реакції обидва nastya house а
поки ви не вигляд будуть змінені повинні
позиція змінити ідею чиїх політичних
сил забирайтеся ost варювати коаліцію c
опозиційний блок з липня тимошенка c
сама позначено це
а самодопомога я додому ще за раз все по
ви не робите шкуру не в побуті в бетмені
ну-ка валіть штабу в шкіру на в того
я автономія відчуває і посилається на
організацію нових сил там вона може
вчити курять люди на нових виборах не
буду не буду sabbath і за околицею нею
ряд
чому там ще в Україні людям свого
часто навіть син він обридло коаліція пам'яті
раніше вусики втілив Ти один зони
вони проголосувало за гомогенні врятувати
януковича на 600 днів причиною того, що їм по
трибун був у ряду і звичайно війни та
помолився за раз у нас повний хаос геть і
побачила як погляду я багата полюс на
quality відсік договірняки я the beat
імені
я не думаю я надумаю ще на стукіт багато
рази люди будуть потім доступні розумні
оборот одну силу що ви натискаючи на беляші
на віру
всюди ви світите, а тенденція не думаю
що пісня хаотичною хвалити Іван і
вибору 10 одну коаліцію після хаотичну
quality його навпаки
одну цілісну політичну силу esp
одягаюсь ще все буде а повністю історію
mazda
я правильно розуміє вас прем'єрський
амбіції я вже ще будете на ступні
посади по ви не звернули в процесі
бонусу ritz їх нові хусітів процесі
відбору серед цих цибулин я я вам лави
, не я хочу бути важливим учасником всього
процесу я відповідаю нову пораду посади
прем'єра все було запитаний вигляд
президента порошенка наблизитися про
що це була пропозиція президента
порошенка тому точки 1 до води 4 мани
посада не сама мета і моя ми ніби
там дає безліч риб і новий
політичний клас україни до класу край
вам шляхи мені покласти в але ж не будуть
куди у нас буду наш ряд наш ряд буде
Деві даси тут-то ви прем'єр-міністр не
там підіймайся
хто фінансовий ваш бог ще наш рук слабо
про фінансово на нас правді ксиви
поважає шукається та офіс профінансовано
це windows та дешево шкіру та похитав та
на кого ви розмови ми партії малого і
середнього бізнесу там і що ми хочемо у
однак у їх провал гри для всіх не
томом і за ви значення монтале графічно
партія but i on the олігархічного
означаючи буде і про-бізнес а м'язи
сам олігарх і душити бізнес розум сбу
диким і поруч він і завжди додаєте з і
поряд з тварюкою свої правила грін і
завищується поля для injuries to
використовую для інших топ то малий і
середній бізнес буду ваші руки назад і
міда сид у грузії у нас було 10 менше
горошині жур hd партії ми з ризиком
вирили вибори ну от дивіться
Михайло цю вісь тиснути а вісь виявимо особі
і досить ситуацію вам дасть рукою і
вибори парламентські ви ваша сила пасі
до цього до серйозного місця якийсь ми їх
вибираємо її в панамі добре давайте
посаду давайте так а я все
президентом завищується Петро Порошенко
вийде до нього прем'єр-міністри не я
кілька у нас буду безчестя сина билися
з ми зможемо провести закони ми
зможемо про дулат і президентську цю
і ми зможемо образ це імпічмент буде
з'явився vlad
види продуктів та порошенку їм листа не
я покараю імпічмент я здається про це буде
інструмент щоб проводять і політику чи
струм ще по зменшувати iso різновид диких з
стрибка для проведення політики
звучу я тут потрібно сина парламент
кабель сисі кобудо гуріді великого будуть
необхідні інструменти
зображував їм я так собачу я думаю ще
народ ланцюга три миша і я думаю що народу
це підтримає у вас імідж та телиць
справедливої ​​burdeos корупцію з литого
нібито 2 ci був і президентом грузії з
правді і freedom house і transparency
підспівує щіток ясна грузія синові в
рейтингу піднялася вдалося і поборотися
за живу корупцію середню корупцію
корупцію середнього ременя вона чи тарна
корупція з геть та здається але я кажу
розрослася а особливо під час вашого
друга терміну ще може націй туристи
це вийде стать на ніссані тенденцію
лютор на корупцію ніхто нікуди не
знаєш про в аптечку захопивши знай ти
результати все елітну корупції і що я
був у почутті ну ті чи ти то я хотів би
пошукати іди результати мої елітні
корупції та transparency та freedom house
через zukul та затишок грузії найнявши 10
крачок міжнародних лічей хочеш знаєте
ще в крал і вона нічого не знаєш
Іван і шакали довго нудно і всюди і не
змив іп знає і результатом нашої роботи
стало тисячі ми реально успішний і бюджет
україни в 11 разив вся концепція
елітарної корупції не стане настя
собачим тому, що я хочу їли тарна
корупція корупції іскрис розумію пече
науку 500 до шансу гривні до відомства
браво на зимових би контролювати ще по
всієї ні чини брав і з зам ви значення
мені можна його обидва риби гниє з голови і
булава здорової або стресові беппо
голова здоровий хост я дивилася я
хочу порожні вам кілька, он і навіть
теоретично шкірно підпорядковується тут
слив а ще а ще вас дозволити Україні
незабаром один українського громадянства буду
нічого будуть втече і на краще висловивши
транзитному залі та q8 міжнарод
в аеропорту було платівки абсурдна
адже ситуація він ти відразу мило а
ще на вас всієї кримінальної справа
закрити грузії закрити закрити а в
сен-симону закрили не кримінальною
справа зафарбувати вас на заклеїти той хто
ви зможете поїхати до грузії і розповім я
в українські політики серйозну тут, а не
збираюся відчинить річковий я нелюбина
якопо ви набиті з поля бою михаїл і а
ще він трамп західну роботу рамка за
кут та вербувальники бізнесменам саакашвілі
треба політичному ви хрестовий туз
отриманий штатах гавкіт думи even
жертвував вино на годину покарав і своїх
публічних інтерв'ю ще добрий ніж і ні в
одному бізнесі а топ саакашвілі мовляв
доведені до банкрутства всі мінгази
еміль хірша за ними і все гірше за мене він
як я kamasan сидиш та він коли вин коли
пачіно я ніколи не хоче , і все moving
azov саакашвілі на бачиш і заміна я cs
прийняв yax арт за раз ми говоримо а про
президента з отриманого штатива не
пробив ликів ви провідного бізнесмена з
було його поле так я бізнесмен ауте
великим відомо бізнесмени тому це
були його погляди як бізнес
я подавилася вашу декларацію повстанню
адже 10 аркушу падаючи там побачила сир і
транспортних засобів флеш велосипед
тільки велосипед і вони не і за раз купив
машину skoda мені купивши skoda skoda
superb ну ж класно машина якраз я
переїхав до кривим томом вона була служба
машина тарик старий а за розкуповують skoda
зараз ти купив шкоду якусь вам за
інтерв'ю вам